[Music]
another thing that we're gonna need when
we go to Mars is food and so probably
that's gonna be growing some of your own
food and we want to do that not by
lugging everything for Earth but by
using what's already on Mars so that
includes using the regular or the dirt
essentially now we know the soil at
least the topsoil on Mars can be very
toxic especially near the surface
everything is desiccated it's just all
dried out but underneath that we see the
soil is very different it's got carbon
hydrogen nitrogen oxygen phosphorus so
you probably be bringing that type of
soil into an area that you then can
create some sort of greenhouse we will
start to grow some food in hydroponic
chambers probably underground probably
using LED lights because we have to
remember at Mars can't just go outside
you know in frozen seeds in the regolith
they're looking at taking microbes to
make meat it's synthetic biology is what
it's called but we're learning how to
make vegetables how they meet how to
make food to sustain the human body the
most efficient way to generate food to
feed people is with an algae farm if you
have a big pool of water you can grow
algae in it and certain strains of algae
have all the nutrients that humans need
eventually however you're gonna have to
terraform Mars itself so that you can
grow food on the surface of Mars